at noon tiny little nipton California  has another new owner and this time it's  from another unexpected place the Las  Vegas Strip Spiegel worlds as it is  purchased nipton for nearly three  million dollars Spiegel world as you may  know is the company behind absinthe and  the atomic Saloon shows on the on the  Las Vegas Strip nipped and sits on the  border with Nevada and about an hour  south of Las Vegas about 20 or so people  live there it was last sold in 2017 to a  cannabis company which promised to turn  it into a pot Retreat and that never  happened Spiegel world says it'll be a  home though for artists and performers  to dream and create we'll have more on  the story coming up later on 8 News Now